big three player draft will be live on
fs1 next Thursday from 8:00 to 10:00
p.m. Eastern Time and then live as it'll
be all about big three basketball on
either F fs1 or Fox depending on the
week the founder of big three basketball
cube and the chairman of big three
basketball a me Trask good to see you
both here on show you got it what is a
big three combine look like oh it's fun
you know guys going at it heart you know
some guys with a lot to prove
you know guys who some guys are not in
the NBA and think they should be you
know some guys you know had a big name
in the league but they still got game
you know when you're a true baller
mm-hmm the NBA doesn't define you you
know I mean you just ball out wherever
you can so we got the big three there
and we got a lot of players as are
really ready to still showcase they
talent on the high level some of these
guys don't mean like hey I've been there
done that I don't need to I don't need
to combine it up I don't need to work
out you put them on the court give them
a ball and it's all-out competition I
mean it's a few players that you know
they know that you know they they've
done enough and you know that it will
sit they they come to the combine some
guys think you got a big enough name I
might get picked off the off the board
you know which is a big mistake
you know he should come to the combine
well of all the new names that I'm
hearing about involved with big three
Greg Oden is one that jumps out at me
yeah cuz is he viewing this as
Redemption or opportunity how is what
what what our conversations Marty either
one of you had with Greg Oden about what
this means I think he's you know a true
baller they just want to play want to
play with his peers you know when you
when you seven-foot tall you don't want
to just go play at the local gym you
know me you want to play with other
seven footers and people who can who can
handle your your skills so I just think
they're coming for the competition some
guys you know they have a dream of
making it back in the NBA
we had a Xavier Silas who was in the big
three last year he went to
and got a 10-day contract with the
Celtics which was cool because it shows
that you can't make it back to the
league with the big three and I assumed
stories like that a me is very crucial
when you're growing a league right well
it's terrific and as Cube says it's a
big big statement and look you're great
came to a game last year we loved having
you my kids loved it it was fantastic
and you saw the level of competition on
the court and and that's one thing that
has opened a lot of eyes that these men
are there to play and as Cube says
they're competitors and this year
they're gonna be in shape it'll be ready
last year you know they said I'll kick
you we'll play in your league and they
really wasn't sure you know was it gonna
be you know 15,000 people like it was
and our first game wasn't gonna be 1,500
people so they didn't really know what
to expect and you know a league a real
league broke out on him and now they're
ready you know they they've been
training since we uh since we had our
championship game and so guys are gonna
be more in shape more ready
the league's gotten younger got players
coming straight you know from from NBA
rosters orgy league rosters onto the big
three so it's a starting to you know
snowball into what we expect it to be
which is a viable league and there are
far fewer spots available than there are
that men who want them so the
competition's gonna be fierce and there
are going to be people who aren't
drafted that are gonna be a little bit
stunned yes really yes you even expanded
the rosters this year right you added a
sixth man - yeah - your rosters this
year we added a we let let the player
captains pick another co-captain okay
another person they really want to play
with so you know this is you know the
last time we're gonna expand like that
so now you have 19 spots available but
we're gonna have over 60 to 80 people at
the combine fighting for those 19 spots
so the competition is gonna be fierce
it's gonna be some players with names
that don't make the cut but what's cool
is insuk
says you want to expand and hopefully
you know we will next year for our teams
down there are you able to accommodate
more players I really want to plan a big
three Cuban a me Trask here talking some
big three basketball and we'll discuss
football and other sports coming up
shortly here so what what what is your
vision of success cube what when you
what do you want this league to be and
you're in your heart of hearts you can
wave a wand and just skip the grown
process what what what do you wave that
wand cares yeah what do you want this to
be I want this to be what people look
for in the summer as you know to get
their sports and basketball fix I mean I
think you know like I said if we're not
around a hundred years I'm gonna be
somewhere pissed off and you know rich
we really have achieved a number of
milestones already the games this year
in primetime all of them as you
graciously mentioned live telecasts it
is a legitimate accepted League and Cube
and Jeff continents have tremendous
ideas for growth but it's on that
trajectory mm-hmm
and we just sign it five year I mean
three year deal with adidas 15 million
dollars so it's great you know that's
why I'm rockin my adidas right now I see
it what you have in particular just
three stripes you got Scrabble okay all
right and so do you have that deal
already locked in here and so you got a
new co-captains already announced to
date Amar'e Stoudemire yes how about
that that's good well Friday night is is
Shabbos though is he gonna be all right
can he roll on Shabbos on the front okay
very good
Baron Davis who I love that guy yeah
he's good too
yeah he's just so you know gym rat you
know guy who you know he's just a leader
yeah I see Wally I see him on turn or
two he's doing a really good job doing
some some media work and go so the same
gym my husband does and he says he's in
shape is that right there you go what
your husband isn't shape oh oh I see
what you're saying okay just want to
make sure Ron Artest yes another guy how
about how about that can't wait for that
no but so isn't he though is he going by
Ron Artest with you or yeah he's taking
it back to our test Jersey did he do
we gotta get you an Artest jersey by the
way is this news or is he is he's not
Metta World Peace
nice matter world peace but just when he
hits the big three Cortese
I think that is news I think you just
broke news so he's not gonna go by Metta
World Peace anymore
not in the big his big three jerseys
gonna say our test do you want one of
those yeah would you support in our test
Jersey what would I be able to do the
Patrick Ewing and put a t-shirt on
underneath you can do whatever you want
okay just wanna I just want to make sure
cuz I don't ever want to run afoul of
you Amy Trask
Sarah never want to do that okay yes the
answer is short that was the long answer
short answer yes okay I will take in our
test Oh hold on killer threes I don't
take that Nate Robinson yes is on the
tries to pick tonight may commence it
Carlos Boozer yes okay now hold on a
second
Glen big baby Davis yes big baby why are
we holding on a second
well I mean did you not see the latest
video of Glen big baby Davis
yeah well it's so is he going to have
his briefcase with him tennis shoes with
him that's all that matters is bring
your tennis shoes okay yeah it's in
trees up our team so he'll bring the
what did he have Brock when you had
chicken and what was that proving that
he was everything was okay I hit a lot
of cash did see that video it past your
your firewall and drew gooden as well
yes that's pretty cool
anybody else that you that you can name
drop that's part of those are the gist
of co-captains who else is new to the
big three this year q well we'll see you
know when they come to the combine and
and make the squad you got to watch the
draft we don't know who's gonna actually
play we got a lot of big names you know
from Birdman you know he's uh you know
the Birdman is coming yeah man okay
signed up to be in a draft pool so let's
potentially get selected well this is I
mean this is fun like I said I went
there last year the one here it staples
you know and I think you guys doing it
live will add also an extra element of
excitement within it within the within
the arena and certainly to folks at home
no doubt okay and who's doing the
play-by-play who know we got Gus Johnson
Jim Shella honest yeah Gus is gonna do
the big three games yes sweet sweet
now we're Tom no I hear two years in a
row now for Gus and and Jim Jackson who
came in studio the other day I you guys
are all set
well let me tell you something about
guests going back to my career in the
NFL yes
what a supportive encouraging man he was
sought me out the first time he saw me
at a game and was just tremendous my
whole career and just a smooth dude you
know he's just that smooth plant
oh I thought you talking about me Gus no
now did does Gus want to do something
with you cube in the studio or something
also other than just did what do you
want to do some music with you cuz Gus
seems to me that yeah guessing like if
you got a little do up in if you and Gus
did something I don't know what it is I
don't know what style of what is it
gonna do like be like Flavor Flav's yes
call my raps you are cube you are the
last person who needs any sort of help
in terms of branding in terms of
anything you want to do career was that
said you must do something
Gus Johnson come on girls let's do it
that would be I think that looking for
Mitchell next part would that go that
would go instantly viral instantly
anything with Gus combined cube right
get using agent I mean I still hold now
for my cameo and a ride-along or
something where's that hey yah we're
back in 60 seconds I do want to talk
about the Raiders there's a couple of
issues in the National Football League
I'd love to bounce off your
your-your-your experienced mind and your
diamond sharp brain in there Amy Trask
and with Amy Trask and cube back here in
60 seconds on the Rich Eisen show
[Music]
all right the founder a chairman of a
big three basketball respectively ice
cube and a me Trask here on the Rich
Eisen show again the combine is next
Wednesday at Santa Monica College the
big three player draft can be seen on
fs1 one week from last night and next
Thursday from 8 p.m. to 10 p.m. Eastern
Time in all games this season broadcast
live on Friday nights on either fs1 or
fox did you demand it have to be gone
Friday you know Friday is my day it is
that yeah you know it certainly is this
day a week so what what do you think
about the Raiders move for Gruden cube
um you know nostalgia you know I was I'm
very like yo just back to the Chucky
days but we'll see you know it's always
weird when it coach been off the
sideline for you know been off the
sideline for a while and come back you
know I know we saw what sorry old boy
Rams did it your meal premiere he did it
so hopefully you know Gruden got the
same thing going for him and we'll see
you know I know he stole the Super Bowl
from conspiring with his old coach Bill
Callahan is that is that something that
was a prevailing thought within the
front office's of the Oakland Raiders
you know say bill change just change the
dam formation you know it the calls the
santen right you know it was a look let
me let me tell you something I've
learned when I'm sitting here with cube
people want to hear from cube okay it
was you're not allowed to do if you
remember that was a Super Bowl the last
time and I hope for the league's sake
the only time that there wasn't the
two-week break in the championship game
in the Super Bowl there was only a
one-week break so I still bristle every
time I hear coach is talking about well
you know we use the first week to get
everything in order and players tend to
their family needs and logistics because
the second week is all football well we
didn't have a second week so you look
it's not excuse making but I'm still
annoyed because
that and we had to plan the stadium and
send ya you shouldn't have to play a
Super Ball in the enemy Stadium hmm that
did in fact happen so yeah so there was
a lot of things that were and we wore
white working against it was a lot of
bad things a lot of bad things
what would al a me think about Gruden
being back and for the amount of money
for which he is back wow that's that's a
two-part question you know that's that's
that's a big financial undertaking I
haven't read the contract so I don't
comment on contracts I've not read well
but we know you know you don't know the
devil is in the details rich is there a
buyout provision is there an opt-out
provision is there a sliding scale okay
no matter how you carve it it is a lot
of money but look the Raiders had some
very very shrewd business reasons for
making a deal like that the team is
leaving a market in which those
magnificent magnificent fans have
supported the team through thick and
thin and they need to keep those fans
engaged for a minimum of a year possibly
more that the team will be there before
they say bye Felisha
now they're going to a market in which
they have a lot of expense that's not
Los Angeles now so that's a mistake but
there you go but look they're the team's
undertaking a staggering a really a
breathtaking amount of debt for the new
facility in Vegas and they've got a lot
of really really expensive product to
sell sweets Club seats sponsorships all
of those things and so signing Gruden is
very shrewd from a business standpoint
he's gonna energize the fan base the
fact though that he is back on the
sidelines in the silver and black is
that something I wanted did he want that
it's not something that ever came up I
mean we never talked about it never out
of the white because of the way it all
broke up now we want on the sidelines
anyone that he believed could help the
team win so it would depend on his
analysis was that going to help the team
win or not so then let's let's let's
dive deeper into the pool and Kaepernick
it would al have sign him amongst
everything that's going on right now if
he believed that Kaepernick could help
the team win he would sign him in other
words I'm not suggesting he would or he
wouldn't I don't know the answer
but what I do know is his analysis would
have been can this man make my team
better can he help us win and if the
answer to that was yes none of the other
issues would impact his decision well I
mean you were the personification of
Davis's groundbreaking management of a
National Football League or a major
sports organization obviously he hired
the first african-american head coach as
well do you think Anton Flores right Tom
floors as well do you think he out would
have been fine with Kaepernick taking a
knee how do you think he would have been
in the meetings you know it's a question
I'm asked a lot I'm al absolutely
believed in our freedoms and our
freedoms to express ourselves he also
was very very very patriotic so
ultimately his decision and by the way
those are not mutually inconsistent when
you talk in and certainly when I have
talked to many many many members of our
armed services their response to all of
this hullabaloo is ami
we enlisted to defend and protect the
rights of others to say that with which
we disagree that's sort of the heart of
what we believe in so those aren't
mutually inconsistent and I'll come back
to the point I made earlier
Al's decision would have been entirely
X's and O's can this player help my team
when it all comes down to it right now
he has filed a grievance to get back in
the NFL and he is deposed an owner a
general manager and a head coach in Bob
McNair Ozzie Newsome and John Harbaugh
in the last two weeks I guess last one
for you on this one Amy do you think the
fact that he has filed this grievance
prevents any owner from going ahead and
being able to look McNair in the face
and say I know he I know he sat down he
deposed you
I believe wearing a Kunta Kinte t-shirt
while he did it and sat there and
watched Bob McNair answer q a that I'm
still signed in the sky do you think
that that his grievance is preventing
him from getting a job right now well if
it is that's absolutely it's silly
because I'm
saying it's silly from a business
standpoint because if the league wants
to cap its damages and I'm using cap in
the sense of CA P not in the sense of
his name right if they want to put a cap
on damages sign him because then even if
in to the extent he proves collusion in
his grievance you've capped the damages
he can recover and limited it to the
period of time the grievance covers just
sign him and let him play like let the
man play football if you can make your
team the question is how can you not
make your team right I mean based on
some of the quarterbacks who have been
signed over the last weeks or months I
mean if I'm a lawyer for the league
right now yes I'm saying as someone if
you want to limit damages that he may
ultimately recover sign him what do you
think of all this cute I think it's
ridiculous I think you know you should
the whole purpose you should be able to
do what you want to do and when the flag
is playing national anthem is playing
you should be able to do what you want
to do at home you doing what you want to
do on the couch on the following you
doing what you want to do this country
is backwards you look at somebody like
Roseanne who hurt national I had the
singing the national anthem was like one
of the most terrible things I have seen
and she's the biggest you know got the
biggest ratings on TV but Kaepernick is
out of a job for taking the knee and
silently protesting this is backwards
upside down it's craziness do you have
any it's a national anthem being played
at any of the big three games we play
them less you okay and is there any rule
or a conversation that you've had on it
no what you want to do okay bathroom
whatever you want to do Cuban a me try
free country Cuban a me Trask founder
and chairman of the big three basketball
league that's gonna be tipping off again
on June 22nd in Houston Texas at the
Toyota Center have you checked the NBA
final dates I mean your froggen is on
the 17th okay
I was just doing off the towel you don't
go to gang we thought we didn't look no
no I didn't excuse me
if there's anybody buttoned up it's you
it that you're the chairman for a reason
I'm sure you're buttoned up but I'm just
I'm just doing this off the top of my
head cuz it could be the Rockets could
be you know having a parade it that we
have a parade coming how do you think
that's gonna play out well by the way we
hear about that a lot from Clyde I'm
sure you do from your Commissioner
Commissioner Drexler how great is that
Commissioner parts about today's
Commissioner glide I still call him phi
slamma jamma that's some old-school
stuff right there no doubt how do you
think the NBA playoffs are gonna play
out
q do you think it's a warrior situation
right here or obviously the East is now
more wide open because Kyrie just had
knee surgery he's done for the year
yeah you know injuries man you know
everybody always picking you know
everybody said Cavs and warriors you
know just just wait and watch the
playoffs but you look up and these
injuries now it's wide open so a team
like you know the Rockets why not be
able to sneak in there get them a chip
in the Sixers I mean the city of
Champions is they're calling them right
now because of the Eagles Villanova and
now the Sixers are that everything's
kind of motive tension six now what I
don't know I mean things are wide open
for them to maybe make it a couple of
rounds it comes back they got a good
squad you know okay it sucks that losing
works the tanking yeah it sucks they
gotta fix that well I think they're
working on that right got to but I mean
it's terrible but dr. J I mean yeah you
you're he's still part of your
organization yeah yeah he's a coach a
tri-state okay very good you know to
lose to win is just it's anti what I pay
watch for last one for you here cubed
your son was here on this show about
what was that about six weeks ago about
a month and a half ago something like
that yeah yeah and I asked him what it
was like to play you in straight out of
Compton and this is I know he literally
really but he did say you had a read for
it though yeah
No you gotta be hey if we want the best
people in the position that can help
make the movie great right and he had to
show he was better than all the other
fake cubes that was coming in about
seven eight dudes who was trying to fake
it but I'm like it's going there let him
know this is your part now were you
there when he read no cuz that would
have been very nerve-wracking nah now I
wasn't there for none of the process
I'm just let him you know go in there
like and get the job well this is what
he had to say when I asked him about it
check it out so which mannerisms of his
do you think you nailed the best the
frown I mean just right there
that was my go-to like during a lot of
my auditions like regular conversations
I was just what do you think he's got
that frown down he got it down I mean
you know how some people yeah I was in
New York walk across the street dude was
like yo Q what's up
where's oh [ __ ] some people say you look
like me more than me ass crazy the
fatherly pride can only go so far it
only goes so far why I really he's
coming back here I think in a couple
weeks think so yeah so he says he wants
to spend like a whole hour here if the
whole show again all sports do this
stuff more than movies and he you know
when you're out for a day he could take
over your desk so I'm definitely okay
and you might not have it when you get
back I say sure well good to see you
guys again thanks for coming in here you
gotta same year Cuban Amy trask again
once again the season tips off on June
22nd in the spot where maybe the
Rockettes are gonna win it all
championship game takes place in
Brooklyn way on August 24th but the day
he really needed peg right now is next
Thursday 8:00 to 10:00 Eastern the live
broadcast of the big three player draft
season to fs1 and you can catch Friday
nights on either fs1 or Fox they live
events of the big three themselves the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience